he said the the you can do like a
thousand whippets in one sitting more
more probably ten thousand but tanks so
I can go through tanks
um and and I asked him did did he ever
feel worried about you maybe going to uh
overboard to overboard with nitrous and
they said oh no no he describes you as
um
like a very calculated almost uh if not
moderating your use just very educated
about it
and you you taught me just a moments ago
that you don't seek to asphyxiate
yourself with nitrous the way I did
I mean I have but uh that's the part
that's bad for your brain nitrous oxide
isn't actually too bad for you but
asphyxiating is very very bad for you so
I try to uh so how many times would you
say you have uh what's called fished out
when you you uh I fish I've fished out
before yeah yeah it feels great I fished
out on mushrooms which is probably my
favorite High wow how does that happen
just ripping nitrous and not getting
oxygen into your brain but on mushrooms
um you eat mushrooms
no I'm sorry you fished out combo
platter oh it's mushrooms and nitrous
fish and a little bit of Xanax that's my
sweet spot
yeah my five favorite drugs and and a
few of them I'm growing out of are are
booze Xanax caffeine
nitrous oxide and psilocybin mushrooms
MDMA isn't that bad too I do MDMA
therapy I do MDMA and psilocybin there
do you really do therapy with that and
I've done ketamine therapy too but I
don't like it as much as the MDMA
therapy yeah I've seen that like
yeah there's a road drive down in L.A
that's like sponsored by ketamine
clinics it's like you're on ketamine
clinics Highway yeah and uh we've heard
about different people doing that is
ketamine Clinic like just a lot of fun
is it like you're
stove to go uh I only did it once
um it was the cleanest ketamine I've
ever done and it's done you know
intramuscularly with the syringe so it
was like a very
it was the most powerful ketamine
experience I've ever had I'm not a
ketamine guy it's a disassociative I I
don't dislike it
it's just not my go-to weed I actively
dislike it's the only drug I dislike
what ketamine is is is just it's not for
me but I'm not mad at it and I've done
PCB before and they're they're basically
kissing cousin they're very similar
right um and it's cool and it's
interesting but it's like it's like when
somebody hands you some like
experimental food like this is
rattlesnake frog raw and then you like
you eat it you're okay that's
interesting not mad at it but I don't
know if I'm running back to order the
rattlesnake fog raw again or whatever
the [__] it is that's how I feel about
ketamine I just go this is interesting
I'm having an interesting thing but it's
not it's not for me and I didn't get as
deep in my
uh emotional catharsis as they did with
MDMA therapy psilocybin therapy what
what what's the high difference between
Street ketamine and like Piers for
Academy well
it's like the way you ingest it like on
the street you're snorting it yeah and
then in the in the clinic you're getting
it you know right into the vein so I
think Street ketamine is basically PCP
PCP is
it's kind of the same thing it's
dissociative and ketamine is like
pharmaceutical PCP no cook in a
microwave PCB started out pharmaceutical
Pharmaceuticals yeah about that yeah I I
love it all yeah I love it all I I just
can't get enough I mean I I absolutely
last time I did an acid I was like I
think I'm done I think I've done enough
acid where I've like explored it and I
think I aged out of it but the first
early acid days were the best and just
you get to a point where with it where
I'm like it's like dirty it glued me to
the floor I was a [__] math lesson I
did it in quarantine and I was a [__]
wreck yeah it wasn't fun I was like oh I
got two hits of the Grateful Dead acid
in my house like the original batch the
sunshine acid that I think I made but uh
I'm saving that for a special occasion
Timothy Leary no he's a famous dude I
forget was [__] guy it's not Kink
easy it's not Timothy Leary like the
Grateful Dead had the guy that designed
their sound system made their acid the
wall oh it's got the wall of powers yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a famous guy
I'm not a dead I don't really remember
his name but yeah
um uh yeah but uh yeah I've had
tremendous help with them so you said
that the the ketamine Clinic was the
most powerful ketamine experience you've
had so you really do get high as balls
high is a [__] kite Academy
dude I went to a
h
like and then like
Kirby from Game Boy was like [__]
dancing on clouds in my mind yeah and I
saw like my my neural Pathways like
combined and unfold and I got into it
was [__] crazy it was crazy I I
remember being on ketamine just
recreationally and in a hotel room I was
in the bath and like looking at my feet
they were like 30 yards away like your
own depth perception just is just warped
yeah like and then I was sitting there
and uh I was in this hotel room the
whole hotel room just went into Free
Fall whoa and I was like I wasn't scared
I was I even looked up and I I like saw
like a shaft that the hotel room was
falling through that's wild and um I
just thought man this is the coolest
thing ever like I loved it the craziest
horror I ever experienced was the toad
Venom the five Meo DMT that was a
[__] most powerful psychedelican ship
and that was again
Mexico City it was [__] crazy I've
never experienced a high like this it's
like mushrooms and acid and everything
is over here and it only lasts like 10
minutes yeah and uh
you you like control alt delete like you
it's a factory reset your entire brain
is like total darkness just emotion you
feel like you're having like 10 000
orgasms in the center of the universe
you're in a different dimension you no
longer exist your body doesn't exist
this room doesn't exist Earth doesn't
exist you go through every emotion
uh it's just like raw emotion in like
the 45th parallel [__] The Fifth
Dimension yeah you're on Neptune and
then I came out of it
crime I mean this is an email topic but
my dad just died of cancer so I went
there for like on some like Eat Pray
Love kind of chip and I was like talking
directly to my dad and bawling crying
tremendous emotional catharsis balling
crying worming around on the ground but
I came out of it with like it felt like
um emotionally ejaculating it felt like
this Great Purge of all this tension and
build up and stress from watching my dad
deteriorate into death and uh it really
really really was a cathartic and
therapeutic experience it's not
recreational there's no room for this to
be addictive or recreational you're out
it's like propofol you're like [__]
you're not
you're gone do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah
dude